gameplay dj lupin iii davi non sono da
vi sono fa vj veniva affanculo
morite tutte se nuovo sport che al
lancio della sedia e divertente giuro
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vj ed oggi sono tornati su è più
ho provato ragazzi a mettere il livello
più vecchio di happy with che esista
vede il primo livello di è più il fatto
in assoluto e questo fatto da jim
bonacci che sarebbe il creatore di apple
ed at i green jobs quindi facciamo il
primo livello in assoluto di nepi
bisogno che cosa c'è fuori bene a parte
come vedi che già luke stava sul cazzo
già all'inizio le scarpe no però quelle
le teniamo per sé non è normale che
muoia l'altra scarpa perfetto stato fa e
devo sopra le colline minchia la prova
di difficoltà del videogioco proprio
ragazzi fantastico carino da è molto
molto meglio di certo papa che vede in
giro per essere primi
non riesco a superare le colline la
difficoltà è questa ragazzi non sto a
superare fantastici o fatta già fatta
perfetto e vabbè era tanto non ti
servono le braccia e stata una purga ma
credo di avercela fatta dove sto andando
mio dio si vabbè delega e tipo
l'ascensore aspettiamo con pazienza
come si fa a perfetto michele fatto male
padrone del 2008 sto vivendo è più viste
sistema nel 2008
io mi sono iscritto a facebook dopo che
è stato creato è più il suo fantastico
perfetto ok non ho più niente quindi non
so oddio chi già è affacciato dato va bè
ragazzi e miopi ed era lenti è la cosa
più bella che abbia mai visto lega cioè
una roba playlist perfetto mi sono
schiantato nova stai calma e non ti ho
fatto un cazzo dalla vita cosa vuoi non
mi ami ha dovuto schiacciare non era
contenta se ben livello comunque non
sempre bello complimenti 29 milioni e
che cazzo è una giocato pure modesto
livello che tanto si chiama corsa ad
ostacoli ce le corse lo stacco di servi
c'erano già all'inizio adesso leggo
livello per fa vj completamente a caso
si vede che lui lo sapeva che avrei
fatto sta è previsto lo sapeva e sa cosa
ho fatto una specie di museo tra
virgolette di happy uil sti cazzo di
livelli ce li ha giocati matusalemme
perfetto perfetta la parola sono un
fenomeno
stavo scherzando non ti incazzare
perfetto lama da quello mi serve amico
mino si chiama intestino lo usiamo noi
sei tranquillo ragazzi non so cosa il
mio culo si sta ingrossando qualcosa non
lo vedo per chi volesse la madre ok
perfetto perfetto tutto il culo cosa ti
ciucci il calzino bravo bravo vedi che
capito proprio suisse c'erano dei rokes
ma veramente l'inventore limbo dei rokes
ming e jim bonacci non lo sapevo io mica
se riuscisse riusciva a raggiungere il
traguardo così a medaglia a gogò prof
l'altro è bellissimo stop singh come
cazzo è che i primi livelli sono più
belli di tutto è primis messo insieme
bello complimenti vi salta in avanti
però frate bravo bravo forza ma come
non si gioca a basket con la propria
testa ma i titoli in testa ho fatto 4
miliardi di rob swing da quando gioco a
the peawees cioè non posso finire il
primo dignitari l'aedes io non so se ti
serve il tomtom
ma se no te lo regalo ecco chi serve
ragazze regaliamo di un ok ok se l'ho
preso madonna ragazzi ma indiana jones
l'equipe proprio a tre mani bravo bravo
devi saltare insieme da sei sveglio
ammazzo delle persone tra le quali jim
bonacci e kay kay cazzo ma è cresciuta
una gamba sul collo ho capito
posso farlo così ragazzi
ma chi sono l'epicità ragazzine gli
avambracci perché i miti è qua c'è
capacità proprio corporeo ragazzi
passati negli normali perché quelli nel
passato mi hanno cambiato proprio
radicalmente nell'anima matrix salva al
melone ecco perché dicevo che è più di
una volta è diecimila volte meglio festa
merda sei lo salvare un melone cioè una
cacata exo morto da zynga bebel livello
complimenti erano più belli quelli di 12
anni fa e che che quelli di adesso ma
grazie possibile rain borbón trova
faccia ecco i ballroom non esistevano
almeno quello vero e come faccia a
uccidere gli hawks fatemi capire a così
ecco the post weight wins abilmente da
far canestro a noi no vinto no no fermi
la mia palla dove andata [ __ ] io
volevo far canestro però posso far
canestro si grazie
non c'è che forza nei braccini questo
succede quando sculaccione gli obesi o
mio dio
gioca uno per uno è affetto adesso ti
togli dalle palle grazie vedi che ha
rotto funziona non si è spaventato raga
pensavo si fosse spaventato mano dai dai
eccolo nel pene diretto questo sport
effetto ragazzi ci siamo fatti valere
anche oggi animation bob com che leggo
su cos'è delle spiegazioni qualcuno ce
la giochiamo a hello kitty duello chitty
chitty chitty perché uno scritto ad hoc
it
eccolo qua perfetto bene cosa la pagina
visita come ti permetti dire
indirizzarmi idiota neanche mia madre mi
reindirizza c'è il adventures hd
proviamo questo ragazzi che ancora non
ho provato una roba in hd ma in happy
wings don't play it feel non giocarci se
il tuo computer e tanto lento e vecchio
perché hai paura che non regga della
grafica del genere zio credimi gaines
c'è una grafica che migliore di questa
dove cazzo ce lo vedo la cadi non lo so
vede solo lui si va ragazza va bene che
accade ma fare un cazzo di ponte che sia
un ponte no è d'accordo ragazzi e porti
al ponte ha impiegato per terra
fantastico è un livello decente
complimenti è veramente al mese milan
c'è questo qua di grafica mi chiama
manco le stesse giocando a crysis ok
spiegatemi in pikachu che cosa mi
rappresenta in saw livello gates di o un
centro al buco allo zio io proposta cosa
son negato non so più
stavo scherzando però stai promettimi
che stai calmo ci prova e ci provo frate
ci provo certo che ci si sucate sucate
sucato tutti grazie perfetto bene e
questo ragazzi all'interno di una china
che lo insegno io non attraversa la
linea zio tu non mi devi dire cosa devo
fare per katy si fa con la famiglia in
due pezzi tanto vinto è perché è perché
io son bello tu no vabbè ragazzi prima
fare i miei livelli per l'ultima volta
prima di concludere l'episodio e
facciamo fa vj frigi non ce la fa gioco
uccidi bile italiano non vuol dire una
bega sta cosa però va bene lo stesso non
ci arriva la moneta non ci arriva la
moneta questa ci arrivo sì bello
complimenti per il livello più bello che
io abbia mai giocato in tutta la mia
vita non so come faccia stare ancora
nella mia pelle
bellissimo
avrà bravo bravo bravo perfetto guarda
adesso disponiamo al louvre dj montagne
russe a bello queste sono montagne russe
son partito di merda per essere montagne
russe fantastiche perso pure il cappello
che mi si vede il riporto ciao fratello
e se il muscoloso si è anche molto bello
di faccia che bella faccia guarda ho
paura di continuarlo per fa vj a poesia
ti stimo favi leggi e fatti due risate
guarda già leggendo il titolo poi sia
per fare la cacca marrone tu sei un
favore
io sono un tuo fan e tu lo sai di già
non esser [ __ ] fa il bravo bambino
né grande favi continua così io faccio
ancora così
dai che vinci
[Musica]
l'utilizzo delle droghe è vietato perché
fa male
pensaci pg 2 milioni la patata al sugo
brass che robbie czeisler stessa ebbene
uno scarso fa vj un mediocre fa vj un
medio fa vj terminati ma che devo
prendere poco un esperto fa vj un
bravissimo fa vj anche lui si droga
pesantemente fratello in dio fa vj fa vj
sceso in terra
non so dove chiede permesso gesù per sé
cose che cos'è 6 fa vj e non mi spiace
mi sa che qua non ci entrò infatti devo
dire che non sono faringei dispiace
ragazzi avere tutta la vostra vita è una
menzogna e che cazzo
ok sono entrato sono entrato sono
entrato non solo entrato non sono
famiglie e ai ragazzi tommy già in bici
ragazzi faccio un ultimo perché ne ho
c'è proprio ho visto dei livelli che mi
hanno cambiato la vita quindi potrei
smettere anche qui però facciamo che
farà anche questo che ora risalta e non
morire
magari se me lo dicevi un po prima
scendi qua dove stiamo andando ragazzi
sondando narnia a narnia ho vinto
perfetto perfetto è quello il mio letto
sempre più comodo del mio letto e
ragazzi concluso che episodio è stato
quel che è stato è stato
spero vi sia piaciuto i livelli di
vecchi di è più il sono 20mila volte
meglio dei livelli di adesso sono
passati tipo sette anni ma non importa è
che i ragazzi spero che la vita vi sia
piaciuto e cosa sento ragazze il video è
piaciuta la scelta mentre è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook che come nei
video trovate la descrizione susseguirsi
di scrittrici vediamo prossimo vito per
ariazzi se quel tizio secondo voi
assumeva droga e lasciato mi piace che
lo aiutiamo parola da ragazzi